alright guys I'm Justin this is Peter we
here at day 3 of CES from GameSpot so
we're just looking at the nvidia booth
they showed up a lot of interesting
things probably one of the biggest parts
though is they're streaming solution we
so PlayStation has their their own kind
of streaming system setting up but
Nvidia has something in the works as
well what is it about i also have got
two different flavors going on what they
called game stream one of them is
streaming locally from a pc that you
have that's got a kepler based nvidia
GPU inside and essentially what you can
do is stream to a device such as an
Nvidia shield hook that up to your TV
and then connect a bluetooth wireless
controller and you can play PC games on
your TV without having to lug a PC into
the living room there are a few caveats
that come along with that such as
latency these are things that are being
worked on it's got a lot to do with your
network it's gonna lot to do with your
TV and your Bluetooth connection but at
the moment it's pretty viable the the
gentlemen we spoke to Andrew fear he was
explaining that it's very similar to a
console and when he sort of broke down
the different components that add up to
latency it sounds like it's pretty much
on par and watching him play it seem
like it's pretty good it was streaming
at about 720p it looked like a at least
a really good console game but the other
factor the other component is the
streaming remotely say from servers you
know in the same state across the
country or maybe even across oceans that
needs a lot more work right now they're
saying you know they have a server in
San Jose and they're saying only people
in Northern California should really try
it but they've got people in Florida
doing it we're experiencing less than 40
milliseconds of latency which is really
very good but again a lot of this
depends on the hardware you're using the
service of they're gonna be launching is
going into beta pretty soon and well
actually it's in beta right now but is
going to be expanding pretty soon and
they don't really have the exact plans
right now in terms of a roadmap for
release date and since you won't be
playing these games on a pc that you own
you'll be paying nvidia as a service to
play these games and those are
relationships they're still working on
so it's still very young but cloud
gaming is really young in general but
and it's in beta so it's not even
something that is necessarily gonna come
to fruition they might see this as
something that really isn't working out
but one thing that is working out is the
g-sync something that they're adding
into two monitors and graphics cards
that's going to improve the way that
games look how does that work exactly so
in
pass what you would you would have is a
graphics card would render frames and
the monitor would have a constant
refresh rate and the relationship of the
rendered frames coming from the card to
the monitor with some time result in
screen tearing or jittering what they're
doing is they're going to hardware
manufacturing saying look take our video
chip put it in your monitor that way the
GPU and the monitor can talk to each
other and they can sync up the frame
rate display so what you have is a
system that doesn't require vsync which
traditionally would tax your PC thus
reducing the graphical fidelity just so
you wouldn't have screens hearing but
now it's done without vsync at all
you'll have different frame rates say 40
and 60 that look as smooth on the same
monitor without having to change any
settings so this is something they're
offering to hardware manufacturers for a
similar price point that traditional
monitored ship manufacturers would offer
them and really it's kind of a win-win
as long as you're buying the video GPU
you may as well buy an Nvidia g-sync
monitor as well so long as the price
isn't too different and it sounds like
it won't be and the last thing that we
checked out here at the booth was a new
chipset for mobile and tablet devices
and it is making some really amazing
looking games or some amazing looking
demos at least right now I guess there
aren't some games running on it yeah so
for android mobile devices and Vidya is
sort of evolving there tiger line now to
sort of incorporate the kepler cuda
cores into mobile devices right now
they've got 192 cores which is
approaching the sort of low to mid to
your range of their graphics desktop
variants and it looks the graphics that
are getting are very good the one caveat
here is our working with OpenGL which is
a really popular and powerful API but
it's not as popular as DirectX what
you're going to see is perhaps people
taking mobile gaming a little bit more
seriously as the graphics are going to
be able to compete with platforms such
as gaming consoles and even gaming
laptops and as you can connect mobile
devices to TVs that's going to be even
more attractive for game developers and
so that about wraps it up for NVIDIA
here it's stay tuned to gamespot com for
all of your CS and other video game
related needs and be sure to follow us
on Twitter and Facebook to see all of
the updates as they happen in real time
thanks a lot
you